then you have the SS now I'm not saying
every guy in this category is a s there
is some overlap where like some guys are
like kind of in between where they'll s
for one girl and be a Chad for another
so there's some overlap but we're just
going to talk in generalities okay now
the next group are the men that marry
Chad's leftover they'll they'll
typically put women on a pedestal
they'll say things like let me ask my
wife because to them the women are above
them the women have this amazing femin
and you can it's more of a mindset than
anything but the the women are just so
awesome and amazing and so special and
you should just cherish them for a
lifetime where the Chads are like
they're just chicks what are you what
are you what are you doing